متنقلا بين شوارع وازقه مدينه عدن يقضي
عمر العشرين عاما سحابه نهاره يقلب اكوام
القمامه بحثا عن قنينه ماء فارغه او قطعه
من خرده البلاستيك
يجمع ما تيسر منها ويبيعها لتجار الخرده
يدفع عنه وعن اسرته شر الفاقه والعوز
يعني خمسه ريال يعني يوميا
يعني
[موسيقى]
هذا ثلاثه دولارات في اخر النهار سيعود
عمر الى بيته وقد كسب ما يسد به رمق اسرته
ليعيد الكره في اليوم التالي ويبدا رحله
معاناه جديده
مثل عمر في شوارع احد بمختلف الاعمار
والفئات فتيه يتسابقون الى حاويه القمامه
ويجمعون ما تراكم من مخلفات وكذلك يفعل
كهول تقطعت بهم السبل ونسوه فقدنا المعين
في بلد وعد من بين افقر بلدان العالم
في اليمن حيث يرجعه الناس تحت وطاه واقع
اقتصادي صعب صار تجميع مخلفات البلاستيك
وبيعها لتجار الخرده مهنه قائمه بذاتها
وتجاره يتعاطاها الفقراء ممن وجدوا انفسهم
على رصيف البطاله تركت فعلا كما قلت من
الاسر الى البحث عن يعني بدائل الكسره
الرزق سواء بجمع الخردوات او سواء بجمع
يعني الاشياء التالفه اعمال بسيطه لا دخل
كثير وانما من اجل الحفاظ على يعني
كرامتهم والعيش يعني توفير لقمه العيش
فبسبب الحرب المستمره منذ تسع سنوات فقد
الاف مصادر رزقهم وسرح اخرون من وظائفهم
ولم يجدوا الا اكوام القمامه بديله